خلطه رخيصه لسلمى
الاجهزه الامنيه ان تكون مستعده لاي
سيناريو وان تكون متعدده الجبهات هذا
المساء اقول لاعدائنا
اي اي رد من قبلكم سيكون هناك ردا حاسما
ضربه قويه من اسرائيل في هذه المعركه كلنا
نقف معا كاخوه انا اقدر الحصانه التي لدى
الشعب
المواطني اسرائيل واشد على ايدي سكان
الجنوب على هذا الصمود
والجيش واجهزه الامن واصلوا الاستماع
لتعليمات الجبهه الداخليه اريد ان اشكر
وزير الدفاع والرئيس هيئه الاركان ورئيس
الشباب ورئيس الموساد وكل المقاتلين برا
وبحرا وجوا الذين يقومون الان بهذا العمل
في لحظه الحقيقه الكل يكون
معا في المواجهه نحن نستطيع ان نتكتل في
مواجهه اي عمليه واي اعتداء علينا شكرا
لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات